just labour is not going to get you
somewhere right kind of action the right
timing correct place all this is
important isn't it the events around you
may not be determined by you but how
your experience of life is on this
planet is 100% determined by you believe
me you're not going to be here forever
I'll bless you with a long life but you
want to fall dead one day if you're
beginning to think that what you're
doing is very important you need to take
a holiday you cannot fight all you
cannot overcome that which does not
exist we have six too many things on the
outside if you fix anymore there won't
be a planet left he's an Indian yogi
mystic philanthropist and author he
founded a nonprofit organization which
offers yoga programs around the world he
also found a project green hand a
grassroots ecological initiative in
India he said guru and here's my take on
his top ten rules for success my
personal favorite clip is number seven
some cures to figure out which one you
guys like the best effort has to be
incisive in the sense it should be
focused calibrated simply if you make
effort it's foolish effort isn't it just
labour is not going to get you somewhere
right kind of action the right timing
right place all this is important isn't
it so for all these things to happen you
need perception and intelligence so
that's all you must do in your life
constantly looking for ways to enhance
your perception and your intelligence
the rest will anyway happen this is one
thing that unfortunately humanity is not
doing they're trying to become capable
of something do not try to become
capable of something just enhance your
perception and intelligence can you see
me right now all of you can you see me
just point out where I am use your hands
and point out can you see me are you got
it wrong you know I'm a mystic you're
getting it completely wrong now this
light is falling upon me reflecting
going through your lenses in what you'd
imagine your ratina you know the whole
story right where do you see me right
now
within yourself where you hear me right
now
within yourself where have you seen the
whole world within yourself have you
ever experienced anything outside of
yourself everything that ever happened
to you
darkness and light
happened with the new pain and pleasure
happened within you joy and misery
happened within you have you ever
experienced anything outside of yourself
no so what I am asking you is what
happens within you who should determine
how it should happen what happens within
you who should determine how this should
happen somebody else definitely you
should determine what should happen
within this isn't it so if you determine
what's happening within this your whole
experience of life will be determined by
you nobody else but you isn't it
the events around you may not be
determined by you but how your
experience of life is on this planet is
100% determined by you if you take
charge of this if you leave it loose
just about anybody will determinate
they're not consciously they also like
you by accident if you if you just
observe if everybody makes a little
effort everybody take a little time for
this piece of life okay
not for your family not for your carrier
not for something else something else
just for this piece of life give it a
little time because this is the most
important piece of life in your life
isn't it yes or no even if you are in
love with somebody still this is the
most important piece of life isn't it so
pay some attention to this how does it
happen why have you taken it for granted
believe me you're not going to be here
forever I'll bless you with a long life
but you want to fall dead one day yes or
no so do not take this for granted if
you wake up in the morning tomorrow if
you wake up in the morning
it's not my wish but I want you to know
of all the people who go to bed tonight
over a million people will not wake up
tomorrow morning and tomorrow if you and
we wake up tomorrow morning is it not a
fantastic thing a million people did not
wake up you woke up
is it not a great thing just look at the
ceiling and smile you are still awake
you still there
and for many many millions of people
somebody whose dear to them did not wake
up so just check those five six people
around you they all woke up wow it's a
fantastic day you woke up and everybody
who matters to you around you woke up
is it not fantastic day you don't think
so yes you don't seem to think so
because the problem is just this you are
living with an idea that you are
immortal when I say you're immortal
you're not actually thinking you're
immortal but you are not conscious of
your morality mortality if you are not
conscious of your mortality somewhere
you think you're immortal isn't it how
many moments in a day are you conscious
that you're mortal
if you were conscious would you have
time to crib
would you have time to fight with
somebody who do you have time to do some
rubbish with your life if you knew if
you are conscious that you are mortal
you would do nothing other than what is
absolutely needed for you and everybody
around you this one thing if you do if
you just remind yourself you don't think
it's a negative thing that is not a
negative thing it's the only thing which
is added value to your life if you're
here forever you would be unbearable yes
you won't be glad everybody dies
wondering if you just become conscious
of this one thing that always you're
conscious that I'm mortal you don't have
to think I will die today we don't
intend we want to live as far as
possible just you know one day I will
die if you just conscious of this one
thing you will naturally become
spiritual every day every moment if you
remind yourself this is a brief life I
motto one day I will end just to do this
for two days and see you will become
something truly fantastic within
yourself just this is all simply
beautiful that's all that's needed if
you want to know the value of life just
know that it's a brief happening just
loosen up your life a little bit laugh a
little more involve yourself with people
around you do things that you think is
not so important don't do things which
are very important
do simple things very important you do
simple things very important things
you're doing in your life you will
become dead serious
you know Bertrand Russell and Englishman
Bertrand Russell said if you're
beginning to think that what you're
doing is very important you need to take
a holiday
so holiday does not mean coming to
Indiana holiday is every day in those 24
hours you must take a holiday from your
seriousness from yourself seriousness
has come essentially because of your
self-importance you hold yourself as an
important person I want you to see you
are like a speck of dust in this
existence tomorrow morning if you
disappear for sure in India nobody will
miss you even Down Under they won't
bother much you know a handful of people
they will also forget soon enough
Lynette sir nature does woof you're gone
and nothing will happen in this world
everything will happen wonderfully well
even if you're not there every human
being should be aware of this every
moment of his life it does not matter
what the whole world says about you it
does not matter how significant a work
you're doing
you must understand that tomorrow
morning the world will go on fine
without you whoever you may be
isn't it so if you constantly remind
yourself of this you'll have no reason
to be serious definitely not dead and
don't be dead now a time will come it's
time to be alive to create fear you have
to use excessive imagination do not be
in fear you don't have to do anything
real is happening because of the
excessive imagination things that have
not happened you're creating what may
happen in your mind happens in thousand
different formats and most probably it
never happens the things that you feared
take hundred things that you have feared
probably 99 of them never happened isn't
it
yes so you're here your fear is always
about that which does not exist you
cannot fight all you cannot overcome
that which does not exist we can
overcome something with that exists you
cannot overcome that which does not
exist you just have to give up that
effort enjoy the fear after all it
you're making you like horror movies yes
I mean you're saying no but you you're
producing them just they're not making
money that's all fear means you're
producing horror movies in your mind
nobody else is willing to watch that's
bad for the producer what you're
producing them so you produce something
else but it's a comedy a love story
suspense filler try and see today
just sit down but use a love story a
suspense thriller a comedy fire five
minutes more noise you make in your mind
really start using your mind differently
it is gotten into a pattern just gotten
into your pattern of just creating
horror movies all the time you have
watched enough horror more is the boring
create something else even it's not that
if you produce these movies those things
will happen in your life still they may
not happen at least you enjoy the movie
in reality it may not happen so what at
least you enjoy what's happening in your
mind if you cannot enjoy what's
happening in the world isn't it that
matter privilege every human being
deserves isn't it so
even in the world is not kind to him at
least his own mind should be kind to him
should produce some nice movies we are
completely committed to one dimension of
our intelligence which we call as the
intellect which is just the thought
process thought can only happen with the
data that you have gathered through five
senses which is very limited one thing
another thing is the nature of data that
the senses gathered are only useful for
survival process the very nature of how
you see things how you hear smell and
taste and touch life is only relevant
for survival process if you wanting to
know the life itself then these
instruments of perception are no good
even what is life and darkness is a
debate between you and another creature
which sees darkness
right isn't it if you sit with an owl
and start an argument as to which is
light and which is darkness it's an
endless argument but who do you think is
right hello if you're saying both you
are either in the diplomatic corps or or
you have a successful marriage you are
learn to say both both but which is the
truth what I see is the truth or what
the owl sees is the truth that's not the
point it is just that nature is opened
up our sense perception as it is
necessary for our survival accordingly
it is opened up sense perceptions for
different creatures as it is necessary
for their survival but if survival is
all you're seeking this is good enough
the five senses but once you have come
as a human being
somehow survival is not good enough if
your stomach is empty there's only one
issue about food but once the stomach
becomes full you have a hundred issues
going on so the nature of the human
being is such no matter what you do you
want to be something more than what you
are right now
and if that's something more happens
something or something or it's an
endless pursuit so somewhere a human
being is seeking a limitless expansion
but trying to do it with physical means
the very nature of physicality is a
defined boundary if there is no defined
boundary there is no possibility of
physical happening in the universe but
now a human being is longing for the
boundless that - in installments and
through physical means through the
boundary you're trying to become
boundless the desire is fantastic the
method is hopeless because the moment
you identify yourself with something
your intellects work is just to protect
that identity if you whatever the
identities of nation or family or gender
or race religion whatever the moment you
identify yourself with something your
intellect will only function around that
to protect that so it is a certain type
of prejudice the moment you are
identified so the only thing I did with
my life is I never identified myself
with anything and life just exploded
within me in ways that thought seems so
puny that I do not indulge in thought
most of the time pleasantness is the
choice isn't it so why is it so much
unpleasantness is happening
human experience because we never took
charge of the inner dimension we believe
by fixing the outside everything is
gonna be okay in the last hundred
hundred fifty years with the advent of
science and modern technology we have
fixed too many things on the outside if
you fix anymore there won't be a planet
left yes definitely this has brought
much convenience and comfort to our
lives in every way we are the most
comfortable generation ever you agree
with me I know you have series of
complaints about how things are not okay
but we are the most comfortable
generation ever before on this planet
isn't it so but we cannot say we are the
most joyful generation on the planet we
are the most loving generation on the
planet we are the most blissed-out
generations our plan definitely not we
are complaining complaining like crazy
about everything like never before this
is because we fix the outside comfort
inconveniences happen well-being is not
happened if your interior tea was
handled by you consciously you would
definitely keep this in a blissful state
so is bliss the goal of life no bliss is
a necessary condition for life to flower
to its full potential otherwise it will
remain constrained
you're paying too much attention to
everything around you not enough
attention to this farm but the quality
of your life is essentially determined
by how you carried this one yes or no
this moment what kind of clothes you're
wearing what kind of car you parked
outside what kind of home you live in
does not determine the quality of your
life this moment how joyful are you
feeling within yourself determines the
quality of your life isn't it so nothing
has been done about it you think it'll
happen in consequence and you're sitting
impossible goals for your happiness if I
have to be happy my wife should be like
this my husband should be like that my
children should be like this the world
should become some other way well these
are impossible conditions you're setting
for your happiness and peacefulness now
that you have compromised yourself to
peace why I'm saying compromising
yourself to pcs because a lot of people
have given up aspirations for being
ecstatic or blissful if I'm just
peaceful it's enough even the so-called
spiritual leaders are going about I'm
saying peace is the highest goal in your
life peace is not the highest goal in
your life if you want to enjoy your
lunch today
you must be peaceful this one
if you're not even peaceful there is
nothing in your life that you can do in
a worthwhile way to be peaceful
essentially means this that you're not
messing your mind to be peaceful
means that your system is at ease you
know how to conduct your mind you know
how to conduct your emotions your body
and your energies you are peaceful it is
not a rocket technology it is the most
basic thing you have a dog at home you
give him his food he sits peacefully
maybe not ecstatic but please feel many
times they're ecstatic also yes if your
dog is able to sit p2o he doesn't have
to run my industry that's not the point
he's got his own stuff going see it has
nothing to do with the external activity
that you're doing it's got something to
do with the internal systems as to how
they're functioning essentially it means
either neither your body now your mind
or your chemistry nor emotions nor
energy are taking instructions from you
they're doing their own thing once your
machine is not in your control being
peaceful is impossible I'll tell you you
get into your car and now you go there
and you want to turn this way you do
this to the steering it goes this way
can you peacefully drive this car can
you no anxiety is natural isn't it this
is what has happened to your vehicle
each out of control you never done
anything to find out where the steering
wheel is first of all this is not that
simple as a car this is a super super
computer now the problem is most people
have not even bothered to find the
keyboard they think if they do this
somehow it'll work if you make when you
are given such a highly sophisticated
machine if you do not conduct it
properly it will cause many problems to
you by accident it's working I want you
to know this this is made this way if
you hold your hands like this
it'll breathe one way if you just turn
it around the very where you agree the
breathing pattern itself changes in your
lungs you can try it if you want when
you have the time this way this way I'm
saying everything that you do
fundamental changes are happening in
this machine because it's such a
sophisticated machine it's more than a
touchscreen if you just wish it it will
happen when you have such a sensitive
and sophisticated machine and you are
operating like a blacksmith then being
peaceful seems to be difficult peace is
not the highest goal in your life it is
the most fundamental requirement don't
were set piece as the highest goal if
you do that your only rest in peace you
must see to be peaceful is the first
thing in your life isn't it if you want
to do anything sensibly in your life if
you want to conduct any situation in
your life sensibly to be peaceful and
happy is fundamental unfortunately in
many ways not just in the way that I
said now in many different ways I would
say 70% of illnesses on the planet all
kinds are self created even if you get
an infection there is a way if you keep
yourself in a certain way physically and
mentally the wireless in the bacteria
will not work the same way as it works
upon somebody else if you set yourself
like this no matter what's happening
anyway I have to go and do this this and
this there's no break from that the last
29 years I have not been able to cancel
one program because I'm running
temperature I got a cold I got this I
got that it doesn't matter what's
happening what you have to do you anyway
have to do you can't turn back on that
either out of your commitment or you
have a boss like that one or one way or
the other if it happens then you will
see you will not at all fall six often
because if you have temperature you
still have to go if it somehow you still
go right now a lot of people don't go
it's a little hot outside they don't go
on work little cold outside they don't
want to work a little raining they won't
go on work
that's no flake they will not go and
work this is just weather so for every
change in weather if you have the
comfort of cowering yourself in a
blanket and lying down once you create
that your body will learn to fall sick
as often as possible if you just keep it
this way it doesn't matter what it is
anyway I have to go and do what I have
to do you will see your body will just
bounce back as quickly as possible
even if you get the worst kind of
infections so you just have to set the
necessary conditions for health
necessary in incentives for health but
for yourself and your children if you
have them do not set incentives for
sickness I was speaking in Nashville a
few years ago I was just telling them a
joke
in the joke I refer to God as him
immediately a few ladies stood up do you
believe God is a man oh I know where
it's going
I was only telling you Duke it doesn't
matter you said him do you believe God
is a man I said I was only telling a
joke it doesn't matter so now there is
an argument going around in certain
parts of America he's got a man or a
woman in India we have no such problems
we have a man God we have a woman God we
have a cow God we have an elephant God
we have a monkey we have a snake we have
flying ones crawling ones creeping ones
every kind because it's a very wise
culture we foresaw all the future
problems that may arise thank you guys
so much for watching I made this video
because more TV RN asked me to so
there's a famous entrepreneur you I'm
going to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do this is a little bit of a different
top 10 so I'm still very curious to see
which of the rules had the biggest
impact on you and why this one goes a
little bit deeper more spiritual so let
me know what you think in the comments
below thank you again so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon raise your standard Apple at the
cool its core value is that passion not
one drop of most self-worth depends on
Europe it's suppose to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top 10 Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details